ayer se vivió en todo el mundo el día de
la Salud Mental para poner sobre la mesa
estas enfermedades que afectan a
millones de personas y es que un informe
de la ONU un reveló que la mitad de los
niños recientes en la franja de gaza
sufren problemas de Salud Mental
mientras que un tercio de los dos
millones de habitantes de ese territorio
quieren requieren apoyo psicológico y
solo cuentan con solo un hospital para
ello por eso saludamos a Raquel Martí
ella es directora ejecutiva de la
agencia de la ONU para los refugiados
palestinos en España Raquel bienvenida
Gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de martes en directo América de
Francia 24 también nos acompaña nuestra
especialista en temas de salud más
Romero sala Buenos días Raquel Cómo
estás
Hola buenos días encantada de estar aquí
con vosotros queríamos empezar
preguntando no por estas consecuencias a
largo plazo que tiene sobre la salud de
los niños estamos hablando eso de una
gran cantidad de menores de edad que
necesitan atención psicológica no la
están recibiendo sabemos que demoras en
recibir atención empeoran las
enfermedades esto a largo plazo cuando
estos niños sean adultos Cómo van a ser
sus vidas
pues muy complicadas porque no estas
secuelas psicológicas que arrastran
debido al contexto en el que se
encuentran en casa Les evita el poder
desarrollarse a nivel educativo pero
también como personas y en el largo
plazo pues todas estas secuelas
psicológicas desembocarán en problemas
de salud físicos y mentales Tenemos que
tener en cuenta que la franja de gaza es
una pequeña un pequeño territorio que
alberga a dos millones de personas que
viven en 365 kilómetros cuadrados y esto
produce Ya de por sí una densidad de
población enorme además la llaman la
cárcel al aire libre más grande del
mundo y eso es debido a que Israel desde
hace ya 15 años no permite la entrada ni
la salida de población y la franja vive
totalmente rodeada por tierra mar y aire
por el ejército israelí este bloqueo que
ejerce Israel que impide a las personas
salir de la franja de gaza pero también
impide al resto de los palestinos
Alemania o de Jerusalén este entrar en
la franja de gaza lo que ha hecho es
colapsar la economía si a esta situación
le añadimos que de forma recurrente
Israel lleva a cabo operaciones
militares sobre la franja de gaza
recientemente hemos sido testigos de
tres días de ofensivas en el mes de
agosto pasado que acabaron con la vida
de un número de elevado de niños y de
personas en concreto 84 niños perdieron
la vida entre el año 2021 y 2022 porque
no habíamos terminado de salir del
impacto que provocó la ofensiva del 2021
y como digo en el 2022 hubo otra
ofensiva está constante ese constante
sometimiento a la violencia hace que
prácticamente yo diría me atrevería a
decir que la inmensa mayoría de los
niños dentro de la franja de gaza
parecen trastornos de estrés
postraumático Raquel yo le quería
preguntar específicamente por las niñas
y las mujeres que viven en la franja de
gaza justo también cuando Hoy se celebra
el Día de la niña son más vulnerables a
sufrir de problemas de Salud Mental a
sufrir maltratos O también por parte de
las personas
Bueno yo creo que en general los niños
están más expuestos a la violencia
porque los niños muchos de Ellos están
en las calles salen a la calle el
problema de las niñas es que las niñas
permanecen prácticamente en sus casas
cuando no van a la escuela cuando no hay
escuela por las ofensivas militares y en
ese sentido están más protegidas de la
violencia externa el problema es la
violencia doméstica cuando hay una
escalada de violencia cuando la
población está sometida a este estrés
extremo tenemos constatado que aumenta
la violencia dentro de los hogares Y ahí
es donde están las mujeres y las niñas
muchísimo más expuestas además hay que
tener en cuenta que están viviendo bajo
una sociedad patriarcal en el que
restringe mucho de sus derechos Como
personas y a la vez estado sometidas a
la ocupación con lo cual viven una doble
discriminación la la presión Israel y la
ocupación israelí y la sociedad
patriarcal en la que se encuentra
Raquel hablaba de 84 menores que han
muerto entre 2021 y 2022 una cifra
totalmente abrumadora Queríamos saber no
estas muertes provocan imaginamos un
efecto no en la comunidad en los amigos
en las familias de los niños que han
fallecido Cómo es esta onda expansiva
que viene de una de estas muertes
Pues a mí una de las imágenes que más se
me graba cuando hay una ofensiva es que
nuestras escuelas al día siguiente hay
pupitres vacíos y cuando los niños
llegan a la escuela el primer día tras
una ofensiva militar que digamos que es
un espacio en el que se van a sentir
protegidos es una vuelta a la normalidad
van a reencontrarse con sus amigos sus
compañeros sus profesores llegan al aula
y se encuentran pues una serie de
pupitres vacíos no Y esto ya es darse de
contra la realidad en ese momento y de
ver que faltan sus compañeros porque o
bien están heridos o bien están muertos
y esto es una constante en nuestras
escuelas ocurre no solamente cuando ella
estas ofensivas la gran escala por parte
de Israel sino que además ocurren a
nivel cotidiano en el día a día puesto
que hay incursiones militares terrestres
prácticamente Todas las semanas Se
dispara desde la el límite periférico
de gafas hay garitas y hay también
máquinas que están armas que están
dirigidas desde tel aviv que dispara la
población cuando se acerca este límite
periférico con lo cual la exposición a
la violencia es constante y esto afecta
muchísimo al desarrollo de los niños
siempre hay un niño en su familia un
primo un hermano o siempre hay un vecino
un compañero que ha sufrido esta
violencia y muchas veces además son
testigos ven Como esos niños mueren ven
Como esos niños son amputado y ven
situaciones horribles en el día a día
que ni los adultos podríamos soportar
Raquel también estabas hablando que la
franja de gaza Está rodeada bloqueada
prácticamente en todos en todo su
territorio por las autoridades y se
realice evidentemente una economía
completamente deprimida casi inexistente
como como existe esta estas personas
allí como viven cómo hacen para
alimentarse además imagino que también
tienen dificultades para ingresar la
ayuda humanitaria a este territorio por
supuesto también todo esto genera una
situación de estrés que afecta
evidentemente la Salud Mental de todas
las personas rápidamente no quiero dejar
eso de lado
bueno eso lo viven con muchísima
angustia hay que tener en cuenta que
este bloqueo ha producido como dice el
colapso de la economía en gaza hay un
60% de desempleo es uno de los antides
empleos más elevados del planeta y
también tenemos que el 65% de esta
población vive por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza un indicador muy visual es
que antes del bloqueo un Road la agencia
de Naciones Unidas para los resultados
de Palestina alimentaba a 80.000
personas hoy en día 15 años después de
bloqueo alimentamos a un millón 200.000
personas es más de la mitad de la
población de gaza que vive
exclusivamente de la ayuda alimentaria
que distribuye un Rock pero también hay
otras agencias que distribuyen alimentos
al resto de la población no refugiada Y
también Hay muchísimas ongs
internacionales que tienen que ayudar en
todos los niveles en el sanitario a
nivel educativo distribuir kitsénicos
cuando hay ofensivas proveer de
medicamentos a los la situación
realmente es angustiosa porque está
además viven esperando la próxima
ofensiva militar